hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu today we're going to be
learning about attraction and deflection
attraction is when a player attracts a
piece to a specific square often by
using a piece sacrifice deflection is
when a player forces the opponent's
piece to a square often making him
undefended square piece alright so here
it's white to play what's a good move to
attract the black Queen into a powerful
Knight fork Bishop takes c6 exclam now
when the Queen takes Knight takes c7
forking the Queen and the king with
check here it's white to play again
what's the best move to deflect the King
from defending the bishop and help to
prepare another powerful Knight fork
Queen to h8 check now after the King
takes Knight takes f7 forking the king
and queen with check so now for a more
complicated example here it's white to
play can you find the best move to
deflect the f7 pawn and to deflect the
black Queen its Knight takes c6 now here
if the Queen takes then the Queen is
deflected from defending d8 so now Queen
b8 wins the rook or if black decides to
take the knight with the pawn the pawns
deflected from defending the bishop so
now the Queen can take the bishop or
rook takes is our last option and now
Knight f4 gives white huge initiative
and we can think about pushing the pawn
later
all right so today we learned about
attraction and deflection two great
themes to remember during your chess
games thanks for learning about it with
me Lulu and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe